should we fix the microbiome in allotransplant recipients? Let's consider these two scenarios.
In both scenarios, things that we do before and early after transplant, such as antibiotics,
chemoradiation as part of the conditioning, nutritional changes, these will cause disruptions
to the gut microbiome, which we collectively know as dysbiosis. Now, in scenario one,
it's this dysbiosis that will directly cause some of the bad outcomes that we see after transplant,
whereas in the other scenario, dysbiosis is simply a surrogate for the fact that there's
a lot going on with that patient, and maybe it's those things that caused the bad outcomes,
not dysbiosis itself. Now, why is this distinction important? It's because
it's only in the first scenario that fixing the gut microbiome has a potential to improve
outcomes. But in either scenario, you would find an association, which could be very, very strong,
between dysbiosis and outcomes. It won't exceed an association if it was a non-causal relationship.
So let's see if we even know for sure there is an association, let alone the causality. So the largest
association that we have with dysbiosis, which is a non-causal relationship, is a non-causal relationship.
So let's see if we even know for sure there is an association, which is a non-causal relationship.
It comes from the retrospective study shown on the left, several thousand patients from several
centers, different countries. When you combine them, there was a significant association between
gut microbiota diversity at the time of neutrophil engraftment and non-relapse mortality. So
patients with lower diversity had higher rates of NRM. The animal on the right shows the
largest prospective series, which is not published, but where this comes from is from the CTN-1801,
which was the correlative part of CTN-1703, which randomized patients between tacmetotrexate
and PTCI for GVHD prophylaxis. And the same association could not be reproduced here.
Now, there are potential arguments that half of these patients got PTCI, and
if you remove the T cells or deactivate the T cells that are alloreactive to microbial antigens,
then maybe the presence or absence of those antigens doesn't matter as much.
But you see the same kind of loss of efficacy signals when you move from non-randomized to
randomized trials. On the left, you see a non-randomized study comparing a group of
patients who got a prebiotic compared to a non-randomized study. And you see a non-randomized
study comparing a group of patients who got a prebiotic compared to a non-randomized study.
And you see a non-randomized study comparing a group of patients who got a prebiotic compared to
a non-randomized study. And you see a non-randomized study comparing a group of patients who got a prebiotic
a historical cohort, and you see a reduction, or I should say a lower rate of GVHD in the
experimental group. But the plots on the right come from a randomized antibiotic trial. It's a
1999 trial, but nonetheless, a randomized trial comparing Cipro plus Flagyl with Cipro alone
in arrow transplant patients. And at the time, you know, there was not much in terms of microbiome
studies, so they couldn't really show what actually happened in the gut microbiome of
these patients. But one would think with the addition of metronidazole, there were some
anaerobes of the gut that were destroyed, and these are exactly the species that we think are
beneficial for gut barrier protection and protection against GVHD. Nonetheless, the risk
of GVHD in those patients is very high. And so, you know, it's a very, very, very, very, very,
very, very high risk. But the risk of GVHD in those patients who presumably had gut decontamination
for those species was lower. So opposite to what we think today. Now, you might say, well, this is
an older study. Let's look at some modern studies. And these are two of them, both double-blind,
placebo-controlled randomized clinical trials. The one on the left used the probiotic lactobacillus
that showed no difference compared to a placebo group for GVHD. And the one on the right is from
our own trial a couple of years ago, where the intervention was really holistic with fecal
microbiota transplant from healthy donors to completely replace the gut microbiome.
And if anything, the rates of GVHD were numerically higher in the FMT arm. So this was the
fact that the intervention was extremely effective on the gut microbiome. As you see on the right,
the diversity of the gut microbiome went up after FMT as opposed to placebo. And the primary
endpoint of the trial, which was infection, was not significantly different between the two arms
either. So in the mouse setting, things are very clean, very nice. Animals that are exposed to an
infection are very clean. So in the mouse setting, things are very clean, very nice. Animals that are exposed to an
infection are very clean, very nice. Animals that are exposed to an infection are very clean, very nice.
So in this trial, you find a very interesting pattern that engraftment of the donor microbiota
seems to matter a lot. Patients in whom these donor microbiota engrafted well, those are in the
bottom curve, had a much, much lower incidence of acute GVHD grade 2 to 4 compared to those who
really didn't engraft well, which immediately raised the hypothesis that what if we try
something that improves microbiota engraftment? Will we be able to improve the microbiota engraftment
then be able to prevent GVHD perhaps? And so we attempted two different strategies. One was by just
simply increasing the dose of the microbiome in the next trial. And also we compared three different
donors, stool donors, to see if one was particularly more potent in engrafting their microbiome in the
patient. And we found both. With this increased dose, the engraftment rate went up by about 25%. And also
we found that the FMT donor 3, which is shown on the top, was distinctly better than the other two donors in terms of engraftment. And then in the randomized phase of this trial, the product, the FMT product, is being manufactured only from this winner donor. And it's being compared to placebo with a clinical endpoint of grade 3 to 4 GVHD. It's double blind, placebo controlled. And we've completed enrollment, randomization. Hopefully we will have some data at ASH. So my conclusions are I think the effect size is probably
small for microbiome. That's why we see a lot of inconsistencies. And that's why in the complex human setting, randomized trials are the only path forward. Thank you.